I've got a two-by-two matrix here let's
say a is equal to a b c d so i'm going
to keep it really general so this is
really any two-by-two matrix and what i
want to do is use our technique for
finding an inverse of this matrix to
essentially find a formula for the
inverse of a 2x2 matrix so i want to
essentially find a inverse and i want to
do it just using a formula that it just
applies to this matrix right here so how
can i do that well we know a technique
we just create an Augmented matrix so
let's just create an Augmented matrix
right here so we have a b c d and we
augment it with the identity in r2 so 1
0 0 1 and we know if we perform a series
of row operations on this Augmented
matrix to get the left hand side and
reduced row echelon form the right hand
side if the reduced row echelon form you
gets to the identity then the right hand
side is going to be the inverse so let's
do it with in this general case not
dealing with particular numbers here so
the first thing I want to do or I would
like to do is I would like to 0 this guy
out right what we want to do is want to
zero that out your that out and then
these two terms have to become equal to
1 so the best way to zero this out let's
perform a little bit of a let's perform
a little transformation here so if I
perform the transformation on the
columns so if I perform a transformation
on the columns c1 so those are the
entries of a column this would be one
column right here that would be another
column right there that's the third
column that's the fourth column but the
transformation I'm going to perform on
each of these columns and we know this
is equivalent to a row operation is
going to be equal to since I want to
zero this one out I'm going to keep my
first row the same this is going to be
c1 and I'm going to replace my second
row with a times my second row minus C
times C times my first row now why am i
doing that because a times c minus c
times a is going to be 0 so this guy is
going to be 0 so that's the row
operation I'm going to perform and I'm
doing this so we can kind of keep track
account for what we're doing because the
algebra is going to get hairy a little
bit
so let me perform this operation so if I
perform that operation on our matrix
what do we have
so our first row is going to be the same
let me start with our second row because
that's a little bit more complicated so
I'm going to replace C with a times C
minus C times a right
that's a C so let me put it this way so
that's going to be 0 right there I'm
going to replace D with D times a right
or a times D write that a times D minus
C times c1 in this column vector so
minus C times B let me write this this
be C and then let me uncomment it and
then this guy is going to be a times 0
because you see 2 minus C times c1 so
it's going to be minus C and then
finally this guy right here is going to
be a times 1 a times this one right here
minus C times 0 so that's just going to
be in a and then the first row is pretty
straightforward we know that the first
row or the first entries in our column
vectors just stayed the same through
this transformation so it's a b10 and
just to make sure it's clear what we're
doing when you perform this
transformation on this column vector
right here you got this column vector
right there when you perform the
transformation on this column vector
right there you get this column vector
right there now I just want to make that
clear because I did it I did all of the
second entries of all of the column
vectors at once because they all were
they all we all were essentially
performing the same row operation so
that just helped me simplify at least my
thinking a little bit let me stay in
this mode so let's continue to get this
in reduced row echelon form the next
thing we want to do is let's make
another transformation call this t1 that
was our first transformation let's do
another transformation t2 or another set
of row operations so if I start with the
column vector c1 c2 what I want to do
now is I want to keep my second row the
same and I want to zero out this
character right here I want to zero him
out so I know I'm going to keep my
second row the same so c2 is just going
to still be c2
but in order to zero this out what I can
do is I can replace the first row with
this scaling factor times the first row
minus this scaling factor times the
second row so it'll be ad minus BC times
your first entry in your column vector
minus B times your second entry and the
whole reason why I'm doing that is so
that this guy zeros out so that that guy
zeros out so if we apply that to this to
this matrix up here let's do the first
row first
so this first entry right here is going
to be ad minus BC times a because that's
c1 you write that down so it's ad minus
BC times a minus B minus B times C two
minus zero so it's just going to be that
that second term just becomes zero fair
enough now what does this guy going to
be he's going to be I'll write it out
doesn't hurt to write it out it's going
to be ad minus BC times B ad minus BC
times B minus minus B times your c2 in
this column vector minus B times ad
minus BC ad minus BC and you can see
immediately that these two guys are
going to cancel out and you're going to
get a zero there and then we got to
autumn nth it I'll make sure I don't run
out of space I should have started to
the left a little bit more so what's
this guy going to be well I'm going to
have this guy times ad minus BC do it in
pink so you're going to have ad minus BC
times 1 which is just ad minus BC minus
B times C 2 so minus B times minus C so
that's plus BC plus BC so 1 times ad
minus BC minus B times minus C is equal
to that you can immediately see that
these two guys will cancel out you're
just with ad and then this guy over here
you're going to have 0 times ad minus BC
which is just a 0 minus B times a so you
have minus a B
- a bee just squeeze it in there and we
know that our second row just stays the
same our second row just stays the same
in this transformation so we had a zero
here we're still going to have a zero we
had an ad - BC will still have an ad -
BC we had a - C and we had an A just
like that now we let me rewrite this
matrix just so it gets cleaned up a
little bit so let me rewrite it right
here I'll do it in my orange well let me
do it in this yellow okay so I have ad
minus BC times a and then this term
right here just became a zero this term
right here is zero this term right here
is in ad minus BC ad minus BC and then
an Augmented part this part was just an
ad this was a minus a B this is a minus
C and then this is an A now we're almost
at reduced row echelon form right here
these two things just have to be equal
to one in order to get reduced row
echelon form so let's define a
transformation that will make both of
these equal to one so this was t - let
me define my tenth transformation t3 let
me define a transformation t3 you give
it a column vector c1 c2 it's just going
to scale each of the column vectors so
what I want to do is I want to divide my
first entries by this scaling factor
right here so that if this becomes a1 so
I am essentially going to multiply 1
over ad minus BC tie times a so 1 over
80 BC a times my first entry in each of
my column vectors and then my second one
I want to divide by this so that this
guy becomes a1 so I'm doing two scalar
divisions in kind of one transformation
so this one's going to be one over ad
minus BC times c2 so I'm just scaling
everything by these two scaling factors
so if you apply this transformation to
that right there
what do we get we get a matrix and this
guy I'm going to divide him by by ad
minus BC times a so I'm dividing it by
itself so that guy is going to be one
I'm going to buy 0 by this but 0 divided
by anything is just 0 is just 0 and then
we're in our demented part ad divided by
so let me write it like this so ad I'm
going to divide by this so it's going to
be ad minus BC times a you immediately
see that the a is canceled out this is
going to be minus a B minus a B divided
by ad minus BC times a once again the
A's cancel out and then in my second row
or my second entries in my column
vectors 0 divided by anything is 0 so 0
divided by this thing is going to be 0
assuming we can divide about by that and
we're going to talk about that in a
second this guy divided by this guy
we're just dividing by himself so it's
going to be equal to 1 now we have minus
C minus C divided by this so or ad minus
BC and then we have an a a divided by ad
ad minus BC and we're done we put the
left hand side of our make of our
augmented matrix into reduced row
echelon form and now this is going to be
our inverse and let me clean it up a
little bit let me clean it up a little
bit so so far we said we started off
with a matrix I'll do it in purple we
started off with a matrix a is equal to
a b c d and now just using our technique
we figured out that a inverse a inverse
is equal to this thing right here and
just to simplify it well let me just
write the way I have it there is I don't
want to skip any steps this is equal to
D D over ad minus BC alright this guy
and that guy cancelled out and then we
have a minus B over ad minus BC because
that guy and that guy cancelled out then
you have a minus C over
ad minus BC and then finally you have an
A over ad minus BC which is our inverse
but one thing might point out just pop
out at you immediately is that
everything in our inverse is being
divided by this so maybe an easier way
to write our inverse we could also write
our inverse like this we could just
write it as 1 over ad minus BC times the
matrix D minus B minus C and a and just
like that we have come up with a formula
for the inverse of a 2x2 matrix you give
me any real numbers here and I'm gonna
give you it's it I'm going to give you
its inverse that's straightforward now
one thing you might be saying hey but
you know not all two-by-two matrices are
invertible you know how can this be the
case where you know all of them and then
I'll give you a question when will this
thing right here not be defined when is
this thing not defined right everything
I every operation I did I can do with
any real numbers and this applies to any
real numbers but when is this thing not
defined not defined what's not defined
when I divide by 0 and when would I
divide by 0 right everything else you
can multiply and subtract and add 0 to
anything you just can't divide by 0
we've never define what it means when
you divide something by 0 so it's not
defined if ad minus BC is equal to 0 so
this is an interesting thing I can
always find the inverse of a 2 by 2
matrix as long as ad minus BC is not
equal 0 and we came up with all of these
fancy things for invertibility you got
to put into reduced row echelon form and
that was you know before that we talked
about being on 2 & 1/2 1 but for at
least a 2 by 2 matrix we really simplify
things as long as as long as ad minus BC
does not equal 0 we can use this formula
and then we know that a and it goes both
ways a is invertible and not only is it
invertible but we can just apply this
formula to it so immediately something
interesting might you know
you might say this is an interesting
number this is an interesting number we
should come up with some name for it and
lucky for us we have come up with Nate
with a name for it this is called the
determinant the determinant let me write
it in pink determinant determinant so
the determinant of a the determinant of
a and it's also written like this with
these little straight lines around a and
you could also write it like this a b c
d but most people kind of think this is
redundant to have brackets and these
lines so then they just write it like
this this is equal to just they just
write the lines a b c d and i wanna make
this very clear if you have the brackets
you're doing with a matrix if you have
these just these straight lines you're
talking about the determinant of the
matrix but this is defined for a 2 by 2
for the 2 by 2 case to be equal to a d
minus bc this is a definition this is a
definition definition of the determinant
so we can rewrite if we have some matrix
here we have some matrix a which is
equal to a b c d we can now write its
inverse a inverse is equal to 1 over
this thing which we've defined as the
determinant of a the determinant of a
times x and let's just see a good way of
kind of memorizing this we're swapping
these two guys we're swapping these two
guys right the a and the D gets swapped
so you get a D and an A and then these
two guys stay the same they just become
negative so minus B and minus C so
that's the general formula for the
determinant of a 2x2 matrix let's try to
do a couple let's try to find so let's
try to find the determinant of the
matrix one two one two three four easy
enough so the determinant of let's say
this is the matrix B so the determinant
of B or we could write it like that
that's equal to the determine
of B that is just equal to that's this
thing right here
1 times 4 1 times 4 minus 3 times 2
which is equal to 4 4 minus 6 which is
equal to minus 2 so the determinant is
minus 2 so this is invertible this is
invertible not only is it invertible but
it's very easy to find its inverse now
we can just apply we can apply this
formula the inverse of B in this case do
it in this color B inverse is equal to 1
over the determinant so it's 1 over
minus 2 times the matrix where we swap
well this is this is the determinant of
V don't be careful B is the same thing
but I with brackets 1 2 3 4 so B inverse
is going to be 1 over the determinant of
B which is equal to minus 2 so 1 over
minus 2 we swap these two guys so they
get a 4 and a 1 and then these two guys
become negative minus 2 and then minus 3
and then if we were to multiply this out
it would be equal to minus 1/2 times 4
is minus 2 minus 1/2 times minus 2 is 1
minus 1/2 times minus 3 is 3 halves
minus 1/2 times 1 is minus 1/2 so that
there is the inverse of B now let's say
we have another matrix so we have the
matrix C and C is equal to 1/2 1 2 3 6
what is the determinant of C it is equal
to we could write it this way 1 2 3 6
let me and it is equal to 1 times 6
minus 3 times 2 3 times 2 which is equal
to 6 minus 6 which is equal to 0 and
there you see it's equal to 0 and so you
cannot find so this is not invertible
not invertible
not invertible so we can't find its
inverse because if we were try to apply
this formula right here you would have a
one over zero but we know this formula
just comes out of that attempt to put it
into reduced row echelon form and in
that last step we just had to
essentially divide everything by these
terms so these terms would be zero in
this matrix see that I just that I just
constructed for you and the reason why I
knew I you know I just pulled this out
of my brain I knew this wasn't going to
be invertible because I constructed a
situation where I have columns that are
linear combinations of each other I have
1 3 you multiply that by 2 you get 2 and
6 so I knew that these aren't linearly
independent columns so you know that
it's rank wasn't going to be equal to so
I knew it wasn't going to be invertible
but we see that here by just computing
its determinant